We now start with our agenda
of developing continuous
counterparts of everything
we have done for
discrete random variables.
Let us look at the concept
of expectation.
In the discrete case, we have
defined expectation as a
weighted average of the values
X of the random variable,
weighted according to their
corresponding probabilities.
In the continuous case, we
define expectation in a
similar way--
as a weighted average over the
possible values of X, weighted
according to the corresponding
value of the density.
Points where the density
is higher--
for example, here--
will receive a higher weight
in this calculation.
But of course, since we are
averaging over a continuous
set, the summation will have to
be replaced by an integral.
This will be a recurrent
theme in this unit.
Definitions or formulas for
the continuous case look
exactly like the discrete ones,
except that PMFs are
replaced by densities,
as here.
The PMF is replaced
by a density.
And summations are replaced
by integrals.
The intuition is usually the
same in both the discrete and
the continuous case.
However, the intuition is
usually much clearer, much
easier to visualize in
the discrete case.
So the best strategy is to make
sure to understand fully
the intuition for the discrete
case and just rely on it.
At this point, let me add
some fine print--
a mathematical side point.
This integral or the expectation
will not be always
well defined.
For this integral to make sense,
we will need to make
the assumption that the integral
of the absolute value
of little x, weighted according
to the density,
gives us a finite result.
Unless we explicitly say
something different, we will
always assume that we're dealing
with random variables
that satisfy this condition.
And so the expectation is well
defined mathematically.
Coming back to the big
picture, regarding
expectations, the intuition
remains the same as in the
discrete case-- that the
expectation represents the
average of the values we expect
to see in a very large
number of independent
repetitions of the experiment.
In fact, there are also theorems
to this effect, but
these will have to wait until
later in this class when we
study limit theorems.
Another intuitive interpretation
that is true
for both the discrete and the
continuous case is that the
expectation corresponds to the
center of gravity of the
probability distribution.
So in this diagram, it might
be somewhere around here.
And similarly, for the
continuous diagram, the center
of gravity might be somewhere
around here.
And if it happens that the
distribution, the PMF or the
PDF, happens to be symmetric
around a certain point, then
that point will be equal
to the expectation.
Expectations of continuous
random variables have all the
properties you might expect.
For example, non-negative
random variables have
non-negative expectations.
Random variables that lie
inside an interval have
average values or expectations
that also lie
inside the same interval.
The derivation is exactly the
same as for the discrete case.
There is also an expected
value rule.
In the discrete case, it
took on this form.
In the continuous case, we
obtain an analogous form in
which the summation is replaced
by [an] integral.
And instead of weighing
according to the PMF, we now
weigh according to the
density function.
The derivation of the expected
value rule for the continuous
case is a little more
complicated than the one that
we gave for the discrete case.
But it's sufficient for us to
know that it is true and that
it has an intuitive meaning that
runs along the same lines
as the intuitive meaning that we
had for the discrete case.
As an instance of how we might
apply the expected value rule,
if you wish to calculate the
expected value of the square
of a continuous random
variable, you
would proceed as follows.
You would integrate over the
entire real line the value of
the function, which is X squared
in our case, weighted
according to the density.
Finally, a most important
property of
expectations, is linearity.
Linearity is still true
for continuous random
variables as well.
And the way it is derived is
exactly the same as in the
discrete case.
Namely, we apply the expected
value rule to this function of
the random variable
X and separate
out the various terms.
The story regarding variances is
exactly the same as in the
discrete case.
We define variances using
the same definition.
And of course, here, mu stands
for the expected value of the
random variable X.
To calculate the variance, we
can use the expected value
rule, which takes this form
in the continuous case.
And we apply the expected value
rule for the case where
we're dealing with the expected
value of this
particular function, so that
in this instance, the
functions g of x is x
minus mu squared.
So by applying the expected
value rule, we obtain the
integral from minus infinity to
infinity, the functions g
of x, weighted according to the
density, and then we carry
out the integration.
We also define the standard
deviation--
same way as in the
discrete case.
We have a property about a
variance of linear functions,
of a random variable, namely,
that if we add a constant to a
random variable, this has no
effect on the variance.
But if we multiply a random
variable by a constant, the
variance gets multiplied by the
square of that constant.
Finally, when calculating the
variance, it is often
convenient to use this
alternative formula in which
the variance is calculated by
finding the expected value of
the square of the random
variable and also using the
expected value of the random
variable, but squared and
subtracted from the
first term.
This relation and this relation
are both derived
exactly the same way as
in the discrete case.
And there's no reason to repeat
those derivations.